[Music]
okay so today
i'm going to talk about google cloud's
managed instance groups
specifically the auto healing feature so
to show you what i'm talking about let's
head over here to the navigation menu on
the left
then down to compute engine and then
over to instance groups
so what i have on this project is one
managed instance group called web app
there it is let's click the name to go
to the overview page
and you'll see that this instance group
is comprised of eight instances
so each of these instances is just an
http application
and it spits out some basic instance
information and also has some built-in
functionality that lets me
change its health state let's go back to
the overview page
so as you can see each of these
instances is currently reporting back as
healthy
and the reason for that is that i have
auto healing configured on this managed
instance group
so let's check out that configuration
so when you create a new managed
instance group or when you edit an
existing one
you'll find the auto healing
configuration down here at the bottom
and all it really is is a health check
so any health check that you have on the
project will show up right here
or you can create a new one up here
it's worth noting that these health
checks are the same ones that you would
use to configure a load balancer
so if you want to use a load balancer in
conjunction with auto healing
you want to make sure that the health
check that you use for your load
balancer
is more aggressive and checks more
frequently than the one you use here for
auto healing
so the reason for that is that if
something goes wrong with one of your
instances
you'd want your load balancer to start
directing traffic away from that
instance
before auto healing gets started with
recreating that instance so once you've
selected your health check you need to
specify an appropriate
initial delay so the initial delay tells
the instance group manager how long
before it should start running the
health check
against the instance after it's
provisioned this is especially important
if you've got any startup scripts or
configuration management
that needs to complete before an
instance is ready to do its job
so i know that this particular
application doesn't take very long to
start up so i've set my initial delay to
just 15 seconds
so if you like to use a cli you use
gcloud
compute instance groups
managed list instances
followed by the name of the manage
instance group
and the region
and that'll return the instances that
are currently in your managed instance
group
along with the zone status and health
state so let's keep this running down
here
while we see auto healing in action so
let's select one of these instances up
here
one rj5 hit the front end and let's make
it
unhealthy and now that it's unhealthy
the health check should pick up on it
so see what's going on let's actually
see the health check that i have
configured for this managed instance
group by going over here down to health
checks
and there's my health check http health
check in use by web app
and as you can see down here that
instance is already picked up as being
unhealthy
and it's currently being recreated so
let's check out this configuration
let's hit edit so what i have here is an
http health check
that is checking against port 80 and
requesting the path health
but you can select from these five
different protocols
if you scroll down here to the bottom
you'll get the health criteria
so according to this configuration this
health check will check
each of my instances every five seconds
if it doesn't get the response it wants
within four seconds it's going to count
that as a failure
so three consecutive failures is going
to mark that instance as being
unhealthy and it's going to keep that
health state as unhealthy or unknown
until it has two consecutive successes
so my managed instance group is in the
process of recreating one art j5
and soon it'll be back up and running in
a healthy state
so in conclusion using auto healing in a
managed instance group
make sure that your instances are
running the way that they're supposed to
and in any case that they aren't they
can quickly and automatically be
reprovisioned and made available to make
sure that your manager instance group
is up and running at full capacity so
that was just a quick look at google
cloud's managed instance groups
auto healing feature
[Music]